hello grammar pals and welcome to the
future full of jet packs and spaceships
and shiny jumpsuits uh and also the word
will
there's a lot of will in the future
by which i mean that we use this word
will
to form the future tense in english so
in the present tense you'd say
i
eat
this
cupcake
that's the present
but in the future
you would say
i
will
eat this cupcake
because
we use the future to talk about stuff
that's happening
later
than now
literally it's in it's in the future so
it's it's later
as opposed to the present which talks
about now and the past which talks about
stuff that is already happened happened
earlier
so the most common way to form the
future is to just make a sentence in the
present tense and then before the verb
just
stick will in there
so
i
pet
the triceratops
everyone's
favorite dinosaur
wish i could pet one can't
they're
extinct i pet the triceratops but in the
future maybe when they clone dinosaurs
i will
pet
the triceratops
and we will be best buds
so that's the most basic way of forming
the future you can also use you know is
going to
so you could say you know
lorraine
is going
to
visit
canada
and that's another way to form the
future but the most common way to do it
is to just put in
will
just write the sentence as you would for
the present tense but then you just
gotta pop in jup will
i eat this cupcake is the present i will
eat this cupcake
in the future
that's the future tense you will be able
to learn anything
david out